but I also want to say the Yukio burg I
love your girlfriend yeah oh why what's
happening I love Cindy
I love since she's the best I would wait
to get married
Bobbie says I should wait what you guys
are considering marriage already I think
we mentioned to me talked about it he's
in love and he thinks he should get
married too
yeah what yeah what indie whatever yeah
and I said wait I would like him to make
it in the business first so I've always
been like I need to change my
circumstances where it's like I need to
be at this point in this this age I need
to have this this this before I can even
do that and I mention that Turek a long
time ago and a lot of my other friends
have shared that same sentiment about
you know their relationships but then
some were like no don't leave your
circumstances hold you back for whatever
you want whether it's marriage or just
something else you want to do I tend to
agree with I don't know what is saying
because it's like there's never the
wrong or right time it's like having
children it's like you know there are a
lot of people who wait to make it in the
business they find that partner they get
married you get divorced you look most
of the people okay did I know that got
married before they got famous when they
got famous
they left their wives as soon as it
happened and they upgraded okay I know
it's mean to say it's not an upgrade
because the whoever will they downgrade
with them during that know what I'm
saying is not a [ __ ] is that
downgrading you think you think it's an
upgrade because she might potentially
she's probably prettier because now he's
got this clout and she's probably taller
but it doesn't mean she's an upgrade the
person who was with him through the ugly
ugly times that's the person and you
know what maybe maybe he might get the
model 10 but he's not getting the model
life this I guarantee that Grady Pruitt
okay we've been doing Connie for one
year this guy this guy is weird
looking he's got eyes on his temple I
just not pick you straight up Michael
Shannon right my photo Mike right so
Grady is a very honest Grady goes yeah
man I never got any girls before
what stand up okay we were at the Waffle
House Saturday night and we saw a
wildebeest a female a woman shaped like
a circle and she was wearing a red dress
and she had like scratch spots on her
face right and she had fat coming out of
this dress on his temple right and she
was like drunk and she was wobbling
right and she was the grotesque Nick
Youssef she was the grossest girl I've
ever seen drunk slobbering white-trash
chick right and I said to Grady would
you [ __ ] hit it he goes a year ago yeah
and that's what I mean right there
before when he couldn't get girls but he
goes now right now I'm getting like hot
chicks mm-hmm right because you've
evolved I mean you did that the level
has changed
I think Cynthia's great no no I'm saying
before her I think he can do better
I've seen before her yeah I was you were
a fatty no no I was fat but then I went
through my whole phase where I was just
gonna say you know my mom in LA but I
was seeing a lot of women I feel like I
wasn't fulfilled from doing that no I
love her India
here's why I think that you know usually
if it was somebody else
if it was another girl and not Cindy
Cynthia Cynthia if Cynthia Cynthia if it
wasn't her I would have been like HeLa
hey bump your brakes Gilbert wait on it
but this girl is beyond I just want him
to make it before he gets married that's
all I'm [ __ ] saying I want to do that
too but I'm gonna bounce figure out if
that's what I should do he's financially
stable she's more than financially
stable she's a fine woman
bricks in the industry she's basically
at the highest level that he can attain
sorry guys I tried to drop my ego yeah
drop your [ __ ] ass I still want a
sugar mama but I think I might need do
you know it's India's the sugar mama
think it's not about Cynthia babes and
Athiya is my sugar sugar mama laughter
oh well then don't do it okay and you
know what I I honestly believe that
everything that I said all this last
podcast has been [ __ ] all right I
should have made fun of midgets I should
have talked about midgets I should have
talked about you Cynthia I should have
talked about any other thing that I ever
talked about this week because I'm so
tired I have no idea I went about to say
some [ __ ] scandalous [ __ ] right now
[Music]